I mentioned this before I want to talk
about it Barack Obama and Mitt Romney
still struggling to come up with great
campaign slogans yeah
something is effective is Obama's 2008
slogan change you can believe in
people love that slogan well President
Obama's new slogan forward has been
getting mixed reactions so this week
both Obama and Romney are trying really
hard to come up with a new batch of
slogans and they're trying them out take
a look we are not going back we are
moving this country forward we believe
in ourselves our greatest days are ahead
I don't get it
I'm not a good person or not a good guy
an idea about starting a great hoagie
shop not familiar precisely with exactly
what I said but I stand by what I said
whatever it was
by simply not up to the task of helping
guide an economy I didn't make a lot of
money in the private sector and don't
understand it did you notice it's
raining outside of that good news I can
fix the tractor
mohei plough a field and chop the back
of a fire alarm and hold the powers or
what I'm really known for
[Applause]
No
my favorite is it's raining out that hit
a nerve with American yeah he's gonna
take that all the way to the White House
that versus hoagie shop yeah